oh
hello everyone um uh thanks for joining
our session
uh it's a pleasure to introduce dr
sergey rigo from johns hopkins
university as our next speaker
sergey completed a bachelor's of science
in human biology in 2006 and a phd in
biomedicine
in 2011 from pancho fabra university
under the guidance of dr
uh francesco sas after that uh he was a
postdoctoral fellow with marcus covert
at stanford university until 2005 when
sorry 2015 when he joined johns hopkins
university as a professor in the
department of molecular biology and
genetics
surgery is the recipient of several
academic awards including most recently
a career award from the national science
foundation and a research scholar award
from the american cancer society
sergey has been a pioneer in
understanding how the dynamics of
signaling networks
impact the behavior of single cells and
his work has been both informative
and inspirational for many scientists
including myself
i think i speak for everyone i say we're
really looking forward to your talk
all right so first of all i'd like to
thank the organizers for giving me the
opportunity
of presenting our work here today my lab
is interested in understanding
how cell signaling in individual cells
allows for coordination of collective
cell behaviors in tissues
over the last 50 years and through a
series of genetic and biochemical
approaches
researchers have identified most of the
components of mammalian signaling
networks
however if one tries to predict a
cellular outcome based on the topology
of one of these networks than boolean
logic
you would realize that is still highly
unreliable and very much cell type
dependent
so in order to address this issue we
have to be a little bit more
quantitative
and identify those nodes of regulation
that are more relevant in each case
but the problem between more
quantitative is that individual cells
even isogenic cells living in the same
environment can be extremely variable
and this is due to a variety of
extrinsic and extrinsic
and intrinsic factors where extrinsic
factors are other cellular processes
that are not necessarily synchronized
between cells in the population
and intrinsic factors have to do more
with the stochastic nature of molecular
interactions
now all these cell to cell variation
make it
such that bulk population assays are
highly misleading so the next question
then is how can we
be more quantitative but have single
cell readouts
and the way we like to approach these is
by using signaling biosensors these
are genetically encoded probes
fluorescent probes
that allow you to measure cell signaling
in individual cells by live imaging
there's a different varieties of these
kinds of biosensors there's naturally
occurring biosensors
like the ones i'm showing here these are
proteins that undergo
a change in localization for instance
upon a certain signaling stimulus
or a change in abundance again upon some
signaling stimulus
but they are naturally occurring
proteins so if we just tag
these proteins with a fluorescent probe
we can
measure signaling over time
in individual cells now besides
naturally occurring biosensors there's
also a variety of synthetic bias sensors
that allow you to measure
things like metabolites gtpa's activity
or even kinase activity as is the case
of these kinase translocation reporters
that work as follows
basically these are synthetically
engineered substrates that have a
fluorescent protein
and about a 50 amino acid peptide that
contains a docking site for a kinase of
interest an nls and then nes in the
context of two phosphorylation sites
so the way they work is when there is no
kinase activity
these two sites are not phosphorylated
and the nls
is stronger than the nes so the
fluorescent signal is mostly nuclear
but when the kinase is activated it will
bind the dock inside phosphorylate these
two sites
inhibit the nls enhance the nes
and you will end up with a net
translocation of the sensor from the
nucleus to the cytoplasm that is very
easy to measure by life cell
microscopy now the other interesting
thing about these sensors is that they
use
one color per kinase so we can
uh use different fluorescent uh colors
and multiplex more than one as this
as i'm showing here this cell line has
four different fluorescent proteins one
um
just dedicated to tag the nucleus for
segmentation and analysis
and three other fluorescent proteins
that allow you to measure irk
jnk and p38 activities in
single cells over time these are not
steels these are videos
where just by calculating their
nuclear cytoplasmic ratio in each cell
we can measure
the signaling activities in those cells
over time
so the next question is why do we want
to use
live cell imaging instead of using
fixed cell approaches like
immunofluorescence
and the answer to this question for me
is to fall
first because it enables measuring
temporal correlations
that means if we had two biosensors in
the same cell we could
know which one of the two pathways gets
activated first
with a relatively high temporal
resolution and in addition and this is
particularly important to us
it allows to compare the temporal
dynamics of different cells within a
tissue
but in addition we by doing these
experiments we have uh
found and others that inferring dynamics
from endpoint immunofluorescence
analysis
can be relatively misleading and this is
for example
the case of nf capability dynamics where
after
stimulation this in this case is uh with
tnf
the transcription factor oscillates in
and out of the nucleus
and this kind of oscillatory dynamics
has been observed also for other
pathways not just nfc like p53
irk and others and uh at the end what
that means
is that if we try to infer dynamics by
looking at endpoint immunofluorescence
it can also be
relatively misleading
so now i'd like to share with you three
different
uh stories from the lab where we
leverage
lifestyle imaging of signaling
biosensors to
address collective cell behavior in
tissues
first i'm going to talk about work by t
making in the lab
who had the following question how
oncogene expression in tissues
alters signaling dynamics in the cells
that express the oncogene but also in
the neighboring cells
and in addition how dynamics signaling
dynamics can inform
cancer phenotypes so the way he
went about these was he created a cell
line
um based on the human breast mammary
epithelial cell line mcf dna that is
non-transformed and chromosomally normal
where he could measure earth activity by
expression of the arc
ktr as you can see this is a very
dynamic
biosensor that again shows this
oscillatory
positive dynamics under basal conditions
now in addition to the irk ktr
tim introduced in this cell line a ted
on
system where he could induce the
expression of an oncogene and measure
dynamics in real time
then he tried about 15 to 20 different
oncogenes
and as a result he found that all
oncogenes can be
classified in two different classes one
class that
will increase the pulsatile dynamics
meaning
increase the frequency of the perk
activity pulses
in those cells and another set of
oncogenes that
increase the activity once and only once
and it remains sustained over time so we
call these
sustained oncogenes and pulsatile
oncogenes
for to differentiate them now in terms
of function
what he did was compare some of the
oncogenes that
created pulsatile earthquake activity
and some that
created sustained air activity and
measured different phenotypes
this was measured by edu incorporation
so what's the fraction of
uh cell cycling cells in the population
and he could see that all the oncogenes
that increase
cosital arc activity have also increased
cell cycle proliferation however
if you look at the genes that have
sustained perk activity
they have a very strong cell cycle
arrest we're now trying to investigate
the mechanism for these arrests but it
really resembles
the previously reported oncogene-induced
senescence
now we totally believe that these is
dynamics dependent and only dynamics
dependent for two reasons
first if you compare b-raf wild-type and
v-600e
these two kinases are exactly the same
they have the same substrates but they
differ by one permutations that renders
the v600e mutant uh hyperactive or
constitutively active
but also because if you induce these
kind of dynamics at different levels
as it's done here with egfr or mac2
you can trigger the same phenotypic
changes
increase proliferation when it's is
pulsatile
and decreased proliferation when air
conductivity is sustained
and in addition to these opposed
dynamics dependent sulfates
on cell cycle we can also see a change
in cell migration but the point of this
study was not only to look at cell
autonomous
phenotypes but look at what happens to
the neighboring cells
so what tim did was now label the
oncogene expressing cells with a
different fluorescent protein a green
fluorescent protein
and infused with doxycycline or not and
measured
the activity in the cells that express
the oncogenes
shown in green up here but also the
activity on the neighboring cells that
do not express the oncogene
and strikingly what he saw was that
certain oncogenes
which again were only those that trigger
sustained urc activity
not the ones that trigger pulsatile arc
activity
we're capable of triggering waves of
earth activity through the neighboring
cells and i'm going to show you here
an example of this striking finding
where there's three examples and you can
see the green cells activate but then
the neighboring cells have these waves
of
arc activity i'm gonna pause this and
play it again
these cells activate first and then the
neighboring cells
uh have a wave experience a wave of
earth activity
so that was interesting to us and we
tried to identify mechanistically what
is behind these waves
um we found out two things first that
they depend on egf
receptor signaling if one adds egf
receptor inhibitor you can
block the neighboring cell activity
while not
affecting the oncogenic induction of arc
activity
but also we found that it depends on the
matrix metalloprotease atom17 which
usually sits in the membrane and is
capable of shedding factors
such as egf like
molecules so what tin did was make a
knockout of atom17 this protease
and use those cells as
the oncogene expressing cells here
or the neighboring cells and what he
found is that if the neighboring cells
are out of 17 there is no difference
cells can still experience these waves
of activity
but if the oncogenic cells are knocked
out for the protease atom17
now the neighboring cells are not
experiencing erc signaling waves
so in conclusion what we think is
happening is that
sustained earth activity is somehow
decoded by the
matrix metallic protease atom 17
and once it's activated it can cleave
growth factor that then diffuses to the
neighboring cells and activates these
waves of erg signaling but what is the
function
of lateral signaling so since these
are these are epithelial cells and and
what we see is
egf receptor signaling one possibility
is that it triggers
proliferation of neighboring cells and
that's exactly what we see
so even though the oncogene expressing
cells
are arrested and suffered this oncogene
induced senescence like phenotype were
upon sustained earth activity they
reduce
the cell cycle fraction the neighboring
cells however this is a cool culture
with only 10
of roughly 600 e cells the neighboring
cells increase
proliferation by more than ten fold by
around tenfold
so this is very interesting to us
because it means that signaling dynamics
depending on the oncogene that those
cells accumulate
can dictate non-cell autonomous
contributions to
tissue growth and it's actually the one
thing cells that are that are growing
around it
but tim also realized something else and
when
we when when he was looking at these
movies he realized that
uh the neighboring cells have a very
striking directed migration
upon induction of the oncogene towards
the green cells and i'm going to show
this in this video
where um we induce with doxycycline
and the neighboring cells tend to all
clump around
um the green cells i'm just gonna go
back and forth in this video
and as you can see there is a very
striking directed migration
towards the green cells that he could
quantify by measuring the angle of
motion of
each cell towards the nearest
grain cell upon addition of doxycycline
there is a strong bias
and this bias depends again on egf
receptor signaling
and atom17 so in looking through the
literature and thinking about it
we thought that maybe this directed
migration of neighboring cells was
contributing to the so-called oncogenic
cell extrusion by which
cells are pushed oncogenic cells are
pushed out of the monolayer
so to address this question what he did
was using a confocal
um and plotting z projections with a
z-stack he could see that upon addition
of doxycycline the green cells are
clearly
up from the monolayer so they are being
extruded
we came up with a way of quantifying
this extrusion
again we could see that extrusion is
dynamics dependent
only oncogenes that have sustained air
connectivity
are capable of extruding and
also he found that these extrusion
depends
on the matrix metalloprotease out of 17.
so if there is
no lateral signaling um
extrusion does not happen so what we
believe is happening
is that depending on whether the
oncogene triggers
hostile or sustained earth signaling we
will have
two very different scenarios one in the
case of pulsatile arc signaling you will
have cell autonomous proliferation
and in the case of sustained erc
signaling you'll have a cell cycle
arrest but then due to activation of
atom17 and
and shedding of egf receptor
uh ligands in this case i'm for reguline
um the neighboring cells will now be the
ones proliferating
and the oncogenic cells will be extruded
from the monolayer now whether this
extrusion
is protective from oncogenic process
and development of malignant tumors
or it in it contributes to
metastasis we don't know yet
so now i'm going to change gears a
little bit i'm going to tell you about
some of helen's work so
helen is a graduate student in the lab
that had the following questions
how do epithelial tissues quantify
pathogen-associated molecular patterns
so what she did was similar to what tim
did
using life cell biosensors to measure nf
capability
signaling dynamics in epithelial tissues
again breast mammary epithelial cells
grown in a monolayer
and stimulated those cells with a large
variety
of pathogen-associated
molecular patterns and cytokines that
are known to trigger nf capability
activity
and measured both the translocation the
nuclear translocation
of nf kappa b this is heat maps where
each line is in
a single cell and each row is a time
and we have the localization and the
gene expression in tandem for each
cell so this is this summarizes about 18
000 cells in one experiment and what she
found from this screen
was that the bacterial lipopeptide pam
3 csk4 triggers a very all or non
response in in epithelial tissues she
verified these
using primary organoids and breast
organized and
got organized now this bimodal behavior
was very striking to us
and so what she did was try to stimulate
cells with other molecules that are not
necessarily in the initial screen
but that signal also through either tlr1
or two what she found is that all the
molecules she tried
that signal through tlr2 or
a dimer of tlr2 triggered this digital
behavior
and interestingly even though she
increased the dose by a thousand-fold
the response seems to be capped at
around
12 13 of cells this is variable between
experiments some
somewhat but it's pretty hard set at
um about between 10 to 15 of cells
so it seems like the upper limit of the
amount of responders
is somewhat limited at the
population level now since this was
all tlr2 dependent inputs what what
helen found out
is that the expression of tlr2 was
limiting so she
induced heterologous expression of tlr2
and could see that
now all cells become responders to these
lipopeptides and in addition she used
single molecule
mrna fish and found that
the responder cells are um
significantly expressing more tlr2 in
fact
the non-responder cells are almost
non-expressers
so how is this tlr2 expression being
regulated was the next
question and what helen found out
through the literature is that there are
several papers that link epigenetic
regulation to tlr2 expression so she
tried a few epigenetic regulators
and found that when we inhibit dna
methylase
activity in cells we can increase the
fraction of responders dramatically
about 60 70
so we thought that maybe the expression
of tlr2 was
controlled by methylation so to in order
to
measure methylation in single cells we
couldn't necessarily do that
but what she did was use nanopore to do
it at a single molecule level
so when we do nanopore sequencing and we
can get methylation
reads we can see how the methylation of
the tlr2 promoter
is bimodal as well so methylation occurs
in block so either
all methylated or all unmethylated
and the fraction of unmethylated versus
methylated reads
maps very well the fraction of
responders and
non-responders in her functional assays
so then we did some modeling and we
realized that there is a certain balance
here where cells have a probability of
switching from responder to
non-responder and from non-responder to
responder
but more importantly helen uh showed
that
if you incubate these tissues with
other inflammatory molecules
these balances of switching from
responder to non-responder or the other
way around
can be modulated and when that happens
the fraction of responders at the tissue
level
changes so what we believe is happening
is that the bimodal expression of tlr2
allows for a tissue level
response so at the at the tissue level
there is an epigenetically regulated
digital signaling that defines
innate immunity
now again i'm going to switch gears and
talk to you about my last example which
is
mike's work mike is also a grad student
in the lab and he had the following
question how
map kinase signaling dynamics patterns
the mammalian
pre-implantation embryo now
in mouse pre-implantation development
what happens is the first few divisions
are
generating um the same
type of cells and you you end up with a
morola that has about 16 to 32
cells which eventually um
develops a cavity inside separating what
we call the truffle ectoderm and the
inner cell mass
now the next step is inner cell mass
further segregates into lineages
one called the epiblast that it's marked
by nano
expression and one that is called the
primitive endoderm that's marked
by a gata6 expression now through the
literature it is clear that earth
activity is involved in this segregation
because if you add fgf4 all
cells choose the primitive endoderm
phenotype
but if you add an erc inhibitor or do an
fgf4
knockout all the cells choose the
epiblast
fate so what mike set out to do
is can we actually express the irk ktr
in mouse and measure our
signaling dynamics while this
specification is taking place
so he first developed the mice and the
first thing that he realized
is that most of the cells of the inner
cell mass are actually
active on perk activity but based on the
genetic evidence
we would expect at least a fraction of
cells that are low on earth
activity so that was surprising
but again the beauty of this approach is
to do
live cell imaging so he used confocal
spinning disconfocal to acquire z-stacks
over time
and he made the following discovery
i'm gonna play a video here this is the
h2b signal this is the irk
ktr signal and i'm i'm going to point
out at a cell that has a very brief
pulse of perk inactivity
so while most cells are active all the
time
you'll see here there how
at some point for a brief period of
about two hours
some cells experience these deeps of er
inactivity um that were the only time
in this inner cell mass development
where we could see low significantly low
earth activity
so then he measured individual traces
of the of a few embryos and the striking
finding was that this
inhibition of perk activity only occurs
after mitosis at no other point during
the cell cycle
there is such an erc low activity again
these are heat maps where each row is a
single cell
and each column is a time the blue marks
mitotic events
and after every blue you have the two
daughter cells
and for example these is an irk what we
call an
arc low division and this would be an
erg
high division where cells resume with
higher activity after division
now to make it more clear we've uh now
done an silicon synchronization of many
of these events
and we can confirm that it's right after
mitosis
that cells experience an irk low
activity
or arc high so we think there is a
bifurcation of urc activity after
mitosis
that could explain um the segregation of
primitive endoderm and epiblast
in in the mammalian pre-implantation
embryo
but to prove that he had to go one step
further and
identify which is the fate of
each one of these cells so what he did
was doing the live imaging experiment
then fix the embryos use antibodies to
do an immunostain
and then re-image those embryos to
register
and identify which cells are which from
the live imaging
to the fixed experiment and
then being all those traces the ones
that are erklo divisions
and the ones that are irk high divisions
and quantify their levels of nano ganga
6
after the imaging experiment
and what he found was that in fact
if you plot the levels of nano and gata6
in each individual cell
and color the dots depending on the erka
activity
right after mitosis there is a striking
correlation where the cells that have
erk low activity after mitosis
tend to have higher nano expression but
the cells that have earth high
after mitosis tend to have got a six
expression
but if you correlate the activity with
uh the last time point just as a control
there is
no such correlation so we believe that
it is the activity of
uh irk after mitosis that helps
um tilt the balance of the nanogata6
expression
uh level and and favor
for the er glow cells nano activity
and therefore epic last um fate
again this would be the summary where
cells
can undergo one of two different fates
after mitosis we have the earth low
divisions and the erg high divisions
and those cells that experience inner
glow division
after mitosis they will
become epiblast they will increase nano
expression
while the er high cells become primitive
endoderm
and so as a conclusion it looks like
mitosis desensitizes
some cells stochastically to fgf
signaling which is present all
throughout this embryo to push the
nanogata6 equilibrium towards nano
so as a summary of everything um we
believe that the main advantages of
studying signaling with life cell bias
sensors are that they capture
uh very heterogeneous behaviors that you
can get very high temporal resolution
and also differentiate cell autonomous
versus
non-cell autonomous behaviors with this
i want to thank the whole lab i've
talked about
mike's team and helen's data
also our collaborators and our funding
sources
and i will take any questions
great um okay so we have
one question um what's the mechanism
underlying er
activity bifurcation upon mitotic exit
and manmalian embryos
yeah so this has been
part of our focus lately we were lucky
enough that the embryonic stem cells
this
bifurcation also occurs so it's there we
can do a lot more
editing and perturbations than
in the embryos and it turns out that
um what we think is happening is that
during mitosis the anaphase promoting
complex the apc
complex degrades the map3 kinase graph
that is responsible for transducing the
signal from fgf down to erc
so that happens stochastically for
different
periods of time and in those cells where
it happens
completely they become desensitized and
then they cannot
transmit the curved signal from the
receptor to the
kinase and therefore its activity is low
nano gets stabilized
and and the balance between nanogun
galaxies
gets shifted towards epiplast uh
awesome um
any more questions any more questions
well uh i guess not so i guess we can
uh close the q a and thank the speaker
for
an amazing talk thank you